[Musique]
on vous présente souvent l'Afrique sous
un jour plutôt sombre il y a une
littérature abondante qui a été qui a
fleuri là-dessus depuis de nombreuses
années on se souvient du livre de René
Dumont l'Afrique mal partie au tout
début des années 60 René Dumont qui
était un écologiste convaincu un
diagnostic surtout agricole d'ailleurs
qui est pas très positif et vous vous
êtes un afro optimiste pourquoi
convaincu aussi parce que je n'ai pas le
même âge que René Dumont et que
l'Afrique a changé je suis assez
d'accord
sous fond ce livre qui évoque à un
moment donné le Dahomey donc
vous êtes béninois qui parle d'ailleurs
des mars de notre établissement
fait dans le prestige enfin je suis
assez d'accord avec le titre pour le
début des années 60 un chiffre que j'ai
trouvé il y a quelques jours j'ai quand
même tombé en arrêt quel peut-être
l'espérance de vie à la naissance
de quelqu'un qui au fond vivait en 1960
au moment de nos indépendances et je
demande autour de moi je demande à mes
enfants je m'en amène à mes amis me
disent ça devait être à 40 ans 50 ans
enfin ça devait être très bas c'est 28
ans au Mali 28 ans au Mali 31 ans
Mali 67 ans au Bénin plus du double plus
du double on a donc fait quand même
quelque chose c'est quand même c'est
quelque chose mais on part assez mal
quand on part avec 28 ans d'espérance de
vie est-ce que ça dit sur l'éducation
qu'est-ce que c'est dit sur le système
de santé publique qu'est-ce que ça dit
sur les rations alimentaires 28 ans
c'est le même chiffre que la France en
1780 on peut prendre 680 et comme vous
expliquer alors justement cette ce bon
en avant
ce que beaucoup de gens ressentent c'est
à dire que il y a tellement encore de
fléau tellement de pauvreté ou
d'inégalité il y a quand même un travail
qui a été fait qui est considérable
alors c'est qu'il résume le mieux c'est
quand même les indicateurs humains
essentiels aujourd'hui un enfant qui
n'est dans
l'essentiel de l'Afrique si vous prenez
la moyenne il a une espérance de vie à
la naissance qui est proche de 65 ans en
disant d'accord c'est un changement
radical ça synthétise bien tout ce qu'il
a fait lu au fond faire changer grâce à
qui alors grâce à Fontaine de millions
de gens qui produisent qui créent qui se
met de temps en temps
on se dit je sais une interrogation de
Gozzi une Gozzi la Directrice Générale
de l'Organisation mondiale du commerce
quand elle était ministre des Finances
du Nigéria et aussi vice-président de la
Banque mondiale elle me disait mais tu
imagines si on avait de l'eau
l'électricité et du capital ce qu'on
aurait pu faire vu tout ce qu'on a fait
avec rien donc si vous voulez il y a un
effort collectif pas tellement la faire
du gouvernement il suffit d'avoir été
premier ministre quelques mois comme ce
qui a été vodka c'était mon cas au Bénin
des leaders et des dirigeants c'est un
travail absolument acharné dans mon pays
et dans quelques pays d'ailleurs il y a
eu des efforts agricoles dans les
dernières années incroyables il y a une
rationalisation de la production parce
que il y a une effort de travail
absolument extraordinaire quel que soit
les difficultés et un effort de
résilience qui est très impressionnant
il y a évidemment des progrès
d'alphabétisation et d'éducation qui
font que petit à petit on rationalise
je me suis mise avec les moyens que l'on
a c'est même sans électricité l'eau vous
savez l'agriculture s'en aperçoit quand
on réfléchisse sur la transition
énergétique en France par exemple c'est
un très grand consommateur d'eau c'est
le premier un très grand consommateur
d'énergie c'est le premier des secteurs
bon ben nous on en a pas donc pendant la
part on est en pénurie vraiment stress
hydrique et en stress énergétique si
vous voulez donc malgré tout c'est un
effort absolument incroyable des
populations labeur extraordinaire et
effectivement quand même un peu de
souveraineté un peu plus de capitaux etc
et donc on a on a fait le travail c'est
pour ça que l'Afrique noire est
aujourd'hui à mon avis très bien parti
avec de mon point de vue des ressources
presque infinies
on dit toujours non non le travail parce
qu'on va avoir la principale croissance
démographique notamment on va avoir un
handicap donc contrairement merci
beaucoup alors ah non non il faut savoir
qu'aujourd'hui c'est un milliard 200
millions d'habitants en Afrique prenez
50 plus une génération de milliards
alors je vous laisse continuer pardon
c'est très simple
la fertilité baisse la fécondité baisse
contrairement à ce qu'on croit et donc
c'est pas de là que ça vient ça vient de
l'expérience de vie vous voyez on va
parler peut-être entre nous 20 minutes
si vous êtes congolais si vous êtes dans
l'Afrique centrale vous aurez gagné
pendant ces 20 minutes 20 minutes
d'espérance de vie nous au Bénin je vous
ai dit on est plutôt à 67 ans donc on va
un peu moins vite que les gens qui sont
encore à 50 50 et donc on va gagner que
13 minutes d'espérance de vie c'est ça
le rythme il est absolument incroyable
donc c'est l'espérance de vie qui fait
la population c'est qu'on va avoir pas
encore beaucoup de gens de mon âge
quand même pour sécurité sociale de tous
les pays du monde et et mes
petits-enfants vont être beaucoup moins
nombreux à l'école là parce que on aura
moins d'enfants beaucoup plus d'actifs
en fait on la voit très très vite toutes
les années qui viennent tout proche on
va avoir la population de jeunes actifs
donc par nature en termes de production
en termes de création en termes
d'entrepreneuriat
le contingent de jeunes actifs le plus
important au monde en proportion de la
population et en cela nous allons
succéder à la Chine et à l'Asie du
Sud-Est qui ont été dans cette position
du plus grand contingent de la
population active jeune dans le monde
dans les années 60-70 jusqu'à au début
du 21e siècle c'est une des clés donc il
y a pas que les ressources naturelles il
y a aussi sont par ailleurs infini
infini mais il y a aussi les infinies
finiront dit par exemple qu'on a
beaucoup de terres arabes et là on fois
que ça c'est important les terres arabes
quand on l'Ukraine et la Russie nous
prive
d'exportation alimentaire
on en a beaucoup plus qu'on croit parce
que on a des avec l'agriculture
d'aujourd'hui régénérative et avec les
technologies agricoles en fait on peut
restituer comme arabe des espaces
immenses vous savez où sont les
principaux
indicateurs d'intensité de rendement
agricole dans le monde non par exemple
où les vaches produisent-elles le plus
de lait en dehors de la notion
oui je vais surprend parce que c'est
dans le désert du negave dans le désert
de l'Arabie Saoudite pourquoi parce que
à un certain niveau de de capital qui
évidemment élevé et de connaissance vous
avez
peut-être qu'on climatise si vous voulez
des étapes mais en attendant quand vous
survolez l'Arabie Saoudite c'est
frappants vous voyez de grands cercles
qui correspondent à l'irrigation en fait
extrêmement vert dans des déserts
extrêmement blanc vous avez en réalité
dans l'agriculture en milieu aride très
difficile ou semi aride comme dans les
pays sahéliens dans les technologies
d'aujourd'hui
et avec tout ce qu'on sait faire sur la
régénération des sols qui continuent à
se dégrader mais si on a les moyens de
le faire ce qu'on restitue comme terre
arabe en Afrique 30 millions de
kilomètre carré en Afrique vous pouvez
mettre l'Europe plus l'Inde plus les
Chine plus l'Amérique du Nord c'est à
peu près ça la taille du continent 30
millions de mètres carrés c'est vraiment
c'est beaucoup et alors dans ce contexte
là ce que vous êtes très optimiste sur
l'avenir est-ce que la solution ça
serait pas le panafricanisme justement
c'est que les pays africains parviennent
à s'entendre les uns avec les autres
oui alors on est on est quand même un
petit peu comme tout le monde on a un
petit peu comme les Européens
on fait des grands progrès d'union
aujourd'hui on assiste à des solidarités
même dans la mutualisation des dettes
européennes des choses qui paraissaient
à des passables à trois ans covid donc
on est comme tout le monde on fait
exactement ses progrès puis je vous en
donner deux qui me paraissent très
frappant un on va créer une zone
continentale de libre-échange
c'est-à-dire un marché unique en
personne n'y croyait maintenant c'est
ratifié et il y a des commissions du
travail tous les jours mais ça se met
petit à petit en place et la raison d'y
croire c'est qu'on a déjà fait
partiellement c'est à dire par exemple
dans l'Ouest il y a une communauté
régionale il y a plus de frontières
autour de la CEDEAO ce qui s'appelle la
commission effectivement de l'Ouest
exactement la communauté économique de
l'Afrique de l'Ouest on a l'équivalent
autour de l'Afrique du Sud à Sadek
autour du Kenya donc on a des
réalisations partielles de ces marchés
uniques pour tout le continent ça ça
sera la plus différentes zones
est-ce que justement vous sentez
aujourd'hui vous connaissez des beaucoup
d'Africains qui vivent dans la diaspora
qui aspirent un revenir chez eux oui
alors ce qui m'inquiète c'est qu'il y a
pas de mots en français pour le dire
alors qu'il y a un mot en anglais donc
ça veut dire qu'ils reviennent plus tôt
en algérien en Afrique du Sud ailleurs
les ripates reparts c'est-à-dire les
contraires de expat exactement c'est la
diaspora qui revient moi j'ai créé avec
des collègues une petite entreprise une
petite banque d'affaires pour l'Afrique
on reçoit
autant de demandes par mois de nous
rejoindre sur le terrain donc en Afrique
de jeunes financiers africains le 25 à
35-40 ans autant tous les mois que ce
qu'on a comme effectivement donc on peut
difficilement embaucher tous les mois
notre effectif non il y a une évocation
absolument incroyable du retour vers
l'Afrique et mais qui est plutôt un
phénomène des élites très formés
actuelle donner du sens à leur vie et
l'emploi de leurs compétences mais font
avec leur patriotisme panafricain le
faire en Afrique en revanche c'est
évident qu'il y a des gens qui ne
trouvent aucun emploi alors qu'ils sont
qualifiés et qui fuient l'Afrique je le
nie pas alors il fuit et puis l'Europe
légèrement sélective c'est-à-dire que si
vous êtes médecin si vous êtes
infirmière vous voyez la démographie
médicale française et européenne
d'ailleurs alors là pour le coup on vous
demande si vous voulez pas en plus une
nationalité Schengen etc et si vous êtes
ingénieur
sur l'Ukraine on se demande de temps en
temps pourquoi les Africains n'ont pas
voté tous contre la Russie mais parfois
ce sont abstenus c'est en partie parce
que tout d'un coup l'Europe accueilli 6
millions du Kenya alors que pour pour
accueillir 6000 réfugiés de guerre de
l'Érythrée du Soudan toute une histoire
la Libye c'était épouvantable c'est
comme ça que il y a beaucoup de pays
africains il faut le savoir oui c'est
une des deux tiers des pays africains au
moins plus de la moitié ça c'est sûr ce
sont abstenus quand il y a eu le vote
aux Nations unies pour condamner
l'invasion pour la Russie un seul c'est
l'Érythrée l'Érythrée mais il y a eu des
substances qui ont étonné comme du
Sénégal ou du Maroc ou du Maroc c'était
où absorption où je refuse de sierger le
jour du vote bon ça a étonné mais du
côté des opinions publiques pas des
gouvernements du côté des gouvernements
c'est plutôt je n'ai pas à prendre parti
je suis dans je suis non aligné dans
quelque chose concerne des grandes
puissances
mais pour les opinions publiques
notamment les étudiants africains en
Ukraine qu'on a refusé d'accueillir dans
les universités de l'Ouest vous venez
crâne
ça a beaucoup beaucoup frappé alors il y
a quelque chose sur laquelle je voudrais
vous interroger on a vu il y a pas très
longtemps la faveur de la mort de la
reine d'Angleterre
qui est aussi la patronne du commonwell
et bien de nombreux pays commémoraient
la mémoire de cette de cette dame on a
vu au Kenya notamment avec
dans la presse beaucoup de tristesse qui
a été
observé dans ces pays et on se dit que
nous avec la francophonie on fait pas
beaucoup le poids face au Commonwealth
et c'est vrai que c'est ce sont deux
types en fait de colonisation qui ont
été complètement différents entre la
colonisation britannique en
la colonisation française
il y en a une qui est
assimilationniste je dirais c'est la
colonisation française colonie de
peuplement d'une certaine façon et il y
a la colonie d'exploitation
associationniste qui est la colonies
britannique non non non
vous voyez eux ils ont des capitaux leur
roi
bien avant Louis XVI Charles 1er
d'ailleurs c'est dangereux de prendre le
nom de Charlène Charles 1er mais Charles
son fils
est revenu sur le trône très vite et
c'est resté une monarchie manifestement
les symboles de la monarchie dans dans
un continent de 1000 royaume fonctionne
très bien manifestement mais là la reine
s'est détachée de l'héritage britannique
au Kenya que vous me montrez l'image il
y avait des camps de concentration
tous les opposants à la connaissance et
les centaines de milliers de gens dans
ces camps de l'époque du Mao Mao la
révolte et ça jusque tout de même à la
dépendance qui s'est faite dans un bain
de sang entre 52 et 62 hein
mais vous savez il y a quelque chose que
les Français devraient lire c'est le
livre du nouveau chancelier de
l'Échiquier c'est-à-dire le nouveau
ministre
du Royaume-Uni il est d'origine ganéenne
il est historien il a écrit un livre je
crois pas qu'il est traduit en français
les fantômes de l'Empire
c'est un tableau terrifiant de ce
qu'était l'Empire britannique en terme
d'irrationalité de brutalité de
incroyable il était déjà membre du
Parlement mais c'est probablement pas
qu'il allait être le numéro 2 du
gouvernement de la grande box c'est fou
quand on dit qu'il y a eu deux types de
colonies une qui a été plus d'une
certaine façon dont la décolonisation
s'est passée moins bien que l'autre
ce que je veux dire c'est on n'aime pas
la reine parce qu'on a aimé la
colonisation britannique j'ai pas dit
qu'on aimait
la colonisation mais en revanche la
Nathan c'est c'est effacer de l'Afrique
et donc c'est le néocolonialisme dont on
taxe la France et dont on ne taxe pas la
Grande-Bretagne c'est injuste non
-Bretagne
c'est beaucoup retiré du commonwei ces
gens vous expliquent comme un ouest en
pleine prospérité et mais dans le
commonweil c'est eux ce qui est con pour
la Grande-Bretagne c'est pas l'économie
kenyane ou même pas l'économie
nigérienne si vous regardez qui sont les
grands investisseurs au Nigeria vous
savez qui sont les principaux
investisseurs nigériens les Français
pourquoi parce que Total a remplacé cher
parce que Lafarge que maintenant
franco-suisse et est absolument majeur
parce que c'est le premier investisseur
français donc faire très très attention
les et ceux qui sont pas européens sont
américains sont du Golfe sont de Chine
évidemment mais ils ne sont pas Bretagne
la Grande-Bretagne c'est énormément
retiré économiquement et au fond il n'y
a pas de néocolonialisme
britannique parce qu'il y a une
indifférence britannique à ces économies
avec quelques exceptions dans les Kenya
fait partie plutôt des exceptions
l'Afrique du Sud au plus haut point est
évidemment
concentrer d'influence et d'intérêt mais
voilà ce qui est pas le cas de la France
avec la France ce qu'on a appelé son pré
carrément sur la planète la France
Afrique aussi
vous avez des pays européens qui se
trouvent être en Afrique qui sont les
pays du Maghreb il était d'ailleurs dans
les limites et de l'Empire romain et de
l'Empire ottoman et qui ont colonisé
l'Espagne enfin bon et là les parts de
marché de la France est comme les
intérêts français très importants c'est
déjà beaucoup moins net parce que les
principaux partenaires économiques
qu'investissement commerce de l'Afrique
subsaharienne sont maintenant la Chine
l'Inde et ou alors l'Europe en numéro 1
mais si on met les 27 économiques
ensemble ce qui est quand même très très
important donc si vous voulez il y a eu
une présence française qui a créé le
sentiment peut-être de postérité
néo-coloniale il y a aussi les symboles
monétaires
oui oui excellente monnaie ah oui vous
êtes contre la suppression du CFA moi je
pense qu'il faut l'aménager si on en
change le nom comme on est en train de
le faire pour l'appeler l'écho c'est une
bonne idée parce que le CFA est
considéré comme beaucoup comme un lien
de dépendance vis-à-vis de de Paris de
la France
et toute une partie de je dirais des de
l'intelligence a ou des influenceurs
africains comme un garçon comme Kémi
Séba par exemple et bien et violemment
contre ce alors cet instrument d'échange
il est Franco béninois donc je le
connaissais évidemment une affinité oui
il me déteste vraiment parce que moi il
me considère comme des défenseurs
acharnés un peu
de la France Afrique de la France
Afrique en général et du CFA en
particulier mais je suis libre c'est
c'est une trilogie je suis content que
Camille soit désormais dans la lutte
contre le franc CFA parce qu'auparavant
il était dans l'antisémitisme et la
lutte contre les intérêts dans le monde
donc je pense qu'il a il a un meilleur
il a une télé il a une meilleure cause
non si vous voulez
cette monnaie on lui reprochait beaucoup
de d'éléments symboliques enfin elle
fonctionne très bien c'est une des rares
monnaies qui n'est pas fondante ne crée
pas d'inflation et c'est pas du tout un
sujet des populations je vous ai promis
de parler du du Dahomey du Bénin vous
êtes Franco Benny noir pourquoi on a
appelé le Bénin très longtemps le
quartier latin de l'Afrique parce qu'il
y a beaucoup de diplômés on les appelait
comment les évoluer c'est ça c'était une
expression
et pourquoi on disait le quartier latin
alors parce qu'effectivement il y avait
beaucoup d'intellectuels alors la
colonisation française était quand même
très fine dans la gestion de ce que vous
avez appris l'assimilation
il y aurait peu d'intérêt
de ressources naturelles peu d'intérêt
et économique on fabriquait des
administrateurs et des enseignants
on a donc beaucoup de médecins on en
exporte beaucoup toujours en Afrique
francophone mais beaucoup en France on
avait beaucoup d'enseignants on a le
record je crois absolument et désagrégé
d'obstétrices si vous voulez comme mon
père typique produit et
mon oncle le président du dôme et des
années 60 a été aussi médecin c'est
tricien et on a beaucoup d'engagés de
droits et voilà et on a
et vous vous êtes agrégés de sciences
économiques oui la valeur oui et aussi
quelque chose c'est on est le pays qui
dépense le plus pour les dépenses
d'éducation pas seulement dans le budget
mais en fait les efforts de famille des
familles pour pour la promotion de ces
familles aussi bien dans l'enseignement
privé etc donc oui il y a un substrat
qui est réel c'est on nous a vraiment et
on n'a pas du tout encouragé
les Ivoiriens par exemple les
Camerounais là il y avait des ressources
naturelles oui voilà donc on a aussi les
par exemple nos militaires dans la rue
française il venaient plutôt du nord de
nos pays
une façon de discipliner des gens qui
auraient peut-être dans le Sahel était
un petit peu moins
assimilable etc c'était bien fait si
vous voulez et puis en fait la phrase on
est qualifié comme ça la fin de la
phrase c'est quand même et bien que ce
soit le quartier de Data d'Afrique sont
tellement compliqués et tordu que
franchement ils sont à gouvernables
alors il y a une chose qui s'est
produite assez récemment qui est assez
exceptionnel aussi c'est la restitution
de trésors
venant d'Afrique en l'occurrence là sont
trésor du de d'Abomey il faut le savoir
on les voit là donc
en deux mots c'est la capitale du
Dahomey donc
qui était l'ancien royaume et donc il y
a eu 26 statuettes
pas que des statuettes d'ailleurs ça
fait 2 mètres c'est pas statuette
qui ont été amusés et vous vous avez une
fondation qui s'appelle Zazou d'ailleurs
qui a été ouverte je crois par votre
fille le 17 ans et qui est qui a été qui
a accueilli notamment c'est en 2006
quand c'était pas en venimé à peu près
les mêmes heures ont été effectivement
prêtés à la demande de Jacques Chirac
2006 c'est l'année d'ouverture du musée
du quai Branly et comme Jacques Chirac
voulait en faire un instrument de
coopération que les pays d'origine c'est
mis d'accord avec le président du Bénin
et nous avons accueilli à la Fondation
ses œuvres et nous avons eu une
fréquentation record où on s'est aperçu
que ça tenait énormément à coeur à nos
populations si vous voulez au dernier
jour le 3 derniers jours de cette
exposition je me rappelle de 2006 qui
était le centenaire de la mort du roi
B11 qui avait lutté contre contre la
colonisation et dont on avait emporté le
on a eu autant de visiteurs qu'un jour
de pluie au Louvre et pour qu'il y ait
des témoins le président du Musée Branly
est fondateur d'ailleurs Stéphane Martin
est venu voir il n'en revenait pas il
n'avait jamais vu quelque chose comme ça
où est aperçu beaucoup d'ailleurs dans
les restitutions voulu accepter par
Emmanuel Macron et à mon avis c'est le
plus grand succès d'opinion ce soft
power français en Afrique pour l'Afrique
c'est peut-être ce qui était le mur et
la restitution des oeuvres d'art oui
parce que ça veut dire notre rapport
devient complètement différent d'abord
ça je les avais pillées ça j'en
reconnais la valeur universelle ça je
vous le rends c'est la considération que
j'ai pour vous c'est une façon de faire
repentance non c'est une façon de faire
justice et volonté de partenariat et
c'est la jeunesse qui s'est mobilisée
c'est pas les je sais pas les
sexagénaires comme moi enfin moi je suis
administrateur de mes
intéressé mais c'est ma fille aînée qui
a fait une campagne énorme là-dessus
mais mobilisant des centaines de
milliers de jeunes africains c'est les
gens qui ont écouté à Ouagadougou dans
l'université un président français qui
s'est laissé interpeller et qui leur a
dit banco voilà pour le reste ça c'est
l'acte le plus important d'après vous en
termes de soft power si vous voulez on a
remonté la France a remonter en
sentiment qu'elle a de la considération
pour les peuples qu'elle reconnaît leur
création il y a eu beaucoup d'autres
initiatives quand il était au Bénin
récemment Emmanuel Macron a annoncé la
création d'une villa Médicis de
l'Afrique pourquoi pour que des artistes
viennent en résidence en production et
qui puisse dire de toute l'Afrique on
l'appellerait cette maison
écoutez ça je ne sais pas je crois que
il y a plusieurs noms un petit peu
géographiques mais peut-être qu'elle
s'appellera aussi Behanzin du nom de
l'homme qui a résisté jusqu'au bout pour
l'indépendance de ce pays merci Lionel
zou merci beaucoup
[Musique]